I have hats giome I've had a weird week
guys I can't sleep I've been sleeping at
10 in the morning and then wake up at 5
in the afternoon like a vampire what's
new no but this is different
10:00 in the morning what is it usually
6:00
wake up at 5:00 still though wake up at
5:00 still but sitting down and then fog
bro you know how to be Friday what oh
[ __ ] so last week my agent calls me and
goes hey you know Lyle live love it or
what's it called love it earlier
love it or leave it I don't know what
that is is that it's a hot podcast which
it is and I go oh anything go doing what
you want it like what is it he goes John
loved it he was a political writer for
Obama I think right Wow each writer for
Obama needs a speechwriter for Barack
Obama
okay and I go well I don't know nothing
about politics and my agent goes you
don't even know nothing is a small thing
it'll be good for your podcast and I
just I didn't even ask any more
questions I can do it so then what I
didn't even know I I wake up Friday and
then you say to me kalila right well I'm
not home so I text him I try to call him
several times I'm like look you need to
be at the improv in two hours he's not
waking up he's not picking up finally 45
minutes before the show was supposed to
start he finally picks up and like you
know you have that show at eight o'clock
at The Improv what show and so and then
she goes did you see the email the pages
and that's when I knew I was [ __ ]
basically the outline of the show he had
to know everything about Koechner he had
to know everything about basically
everything Michael Flynn everything
everything to that outline yeah because
it's structured yeah so then he starts
panicking I think I'll [ __ ] do I can't
do it cancel why you can't yeah because
it's so that just sold-out show at The
Improv and it's through CAA so I can't
cancel so I show up there and
upstairs and I'm in there with two other
people that are doing it
this guy iris he's a african-american
gay guy from MTV analyst not a very
smart and an actress
I forgot her name she was very good
though and I walked up to the John loved
and I got hey I don't know nothing and
you could tell they're like what a [ __ ]
that you're a political pundit and he
goes oh I guess okay really nice guy
though certain it's sold out so you're
doing a live podcast she's sold out at
The Improv and I don't know nothing so
they introduced us I woke up on stage
and I this is what you do do well you
don't know nothing you have to just play
that it's the only card you have played
um you gotta play it no you say I don't
know nothing I don't know why I'm here
oh that sentence yeah yeah you said it
four times already
I'm on stage I don't even know what was
going on it was an hour and a half long
so I'm on stage for an hour to have this
guy John loved it is the best not only
is he immersed himself in the material
obviously he he worked for the White
House he's a writer he's great he's also
very funny and he's killing on stage
I mean he's obliterating and I'm
literally going I'm she did it with the
mic at one point for 20 minutes a mic
was even by my mom I just had a dangling
by my side and then everyone so I would
do this I would just stand up and walk
away it's a good bit I think if that bit
always worked that's a good bit and then
he would have to say what are you doing
I'm taking a break
yeah that kind I was doing that act yeah
yeah and then when it was done I just
ran out of there how long was the show
hour and a half an hour and a half of
walking up and down and saying I don't
know nothing holy [ __ ]
no stuff right so he watches the news
every day I went through each point with
him I'm like look you know about this
trip to Rome you know about him slapping
the hand you knew every point on there
but when it comes to when the pressure
is on it just somehow evaporates from
know because the things that I know is
what your what the things that I know is
how he's introducing the topic all with
the basics yeah so slap in the hand is
one thing yeah he already said that yeah
so then he's like what why did she do
that who was around them yeah what trip
where were they going he was going from
here to there yeah to see this person I
don't know anything else but the
slapping but that information is already
out there so now I'm [ __ ]
I don't know nothing I know I don't know
nothing taking a break yeah
[Music]